>> Laura: THE SUBJECT OF
TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN OVER THE
PAST SEVEN MONTHS AT THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION REVEAL
AS LOT ABOUT HOW BIG
GOVERNMENT CAN END UP
BECOMING A THREAT TO
REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY.
AND THE MORE WE LOOK AT THE
WEB OF CLINTON AND OBAMA
LOYALISTS WHO BURROWED IN TO
MUELLER'S OFFICE, THE MORE
OBVIOUS IT ALL BECOMES.
THERE WERE A NUMBER OF
HIGHLY INFLUENTIAL AND
POWERFUL PEOPLE WORKING
INSIDE THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
WHO WERE NOT ONLY HORRIFIED
PRESIDENCY, THEY WERE INTENT
ON PREVENTING HIM FROM BEING
ELECTED BY ANY MEANS
NECESSARY.
AND IF THAT MEANT APPLYING
FOR A FISA WARRANT BASED ON
A PHONY DOSSIER IN ORDER TO
SPY ON THE CAMPAIGN, MAYBE
THEY WOULD DO IT.
AND IF IT MEANT DEPLOYING
THE ENTIRE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
APPARATUS INTO DEATH CON ONE
MODE, HYPERVENTILATING WITH
RUSSIAN COLLUSION 24/7, THEY
WOULD DO IT.
AND TODAY IF IT REQUIRES
FLOATING A PIECE
FLOATING A SIECE
FLOATING A SPECE
FLOATING A SPECIOUS STORE
THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS EARLY
ON SET DEMENTIA.
RETRACTED BY MAJOR NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS.
THEY DUAL THAT, TOO.
IF IT MEANS PROPAGATING THE
IDEA THAT DON TRUMP JR.,
JARED, AND THE PRESIDENT
WERE IN SOME CONSPIRACY WITH
THE OLD KGB TO THROW THE
ELECTION?
NO PROBLEM, WHATEVER IT
TAKES.
AS THE FORMER MUELLER
INVESTIGATOR PETER STRZOK
PUT IT, THEY NEEDED AN
INSURANCE POLICY TO STOP
TRUMP.
WHY IS THAT SIGNIFICANT?
WELL, HERE'S THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE, BOB GOODLAT.
>> ANDY IS PRESUMABLY ANDREW
MCCABE, THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF THE FEDERAL BUREAU OF
INVESTIGATION.
THEY HAVE A PLAN TO TAKE
ELECTED PRESIDENT OF THE
>> Laura: NOW, THIS ENTIRE
INVESTIGATION, THESE TEXTS,
THEY HAVE AN UNLIMITED
THEY HAVE BASICALLY AN
THE HUNT FOREVER HOW LONG
THEY WANT.
IT'S INSANE.
THE FOUNDERS NEVER
BRANCH COULD HIRE A BUNCH OF
AGENDA-DRIVEN INVESTIGATORS
IN SEARCH OF A CRIME BY THE
HEAD OF THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH.
I MEAN, IF CONGRESS WANTS TO
GET RID OF THE PRESIDENT,
THEY HAVE A WAY TO DO THAT.
IT'S CALLED IMPEACHMENT.
THAT'S THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL
PREROGATIVE.
BUT THIS DEAL WITH MUELLER
IS NOW JUST TOTALLY OUT OF
HAND.
AND AT A MINIMUM, A FEW
THINGS NEED TO HAPPEN
IMMEDIATELY IN ORDER TO AT
LEAST STABILIZE THE
ANDREW McCAPE MUST BE
FIRED, PERIOD.
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION AFTER
HE HAD BEEN A KEY PLAYER IN
THE ULTIMATE EXONERATION OF
THE HILLARY CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION.
AND, REMEMBER, HE HELPED
COMEY SOFTEN THE LANGUAGE OF
HIS NON-INDICTMENT,
INDICTMENT OF MRS. CLINTON.
AND THERE IS A LOT OF OTHER
THINGS ABOUT STRZOK WE WON'T
GO INTO NOW.
YOU ALL KNOW THEM BY NOW.
AND WHETHER MCCABE ACTUALLY
COP SPIDER WITH STRZOK AND
WENT TO THE FISA COURT TO
SURVEIL THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN,
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT,
TOO.
AND THAT ALSO HAS TO BE
INVESTIGATED.
BUT A SEPARATE GROUND FOR
FIRING MCCABE FOR CAUSE MAY
BE THE MEETING STRZOK
REFERENCES IN HIS TEXT
MESSAGES, THE THING THAT WE
JUST REFERENCED.
BECAUSE, IF TRUE, MCCABE
ACTUALLY TOOK PART IN A
ABILITY TO LEAD THE
GOVERNMENT AS PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
THAT TEXT MESSAGE COULD BE
THE SMOKING GUN.
AND AS FOR BOB MUELLER
HIMSELF, INDEED, HE HAS
DISTINCTION.
BUT THAT DOESN'T CHANGE THE
FACT THAT RIGHT NOW THIS
INVESTIGATION HE IS HEADING
HAS BECOME IRREPARABLY
TAINTED.
AS THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL"
JUST PUT IT, THE MAN WHO
SHOULD BE MOST DISTURBED BY
ALL OF THIS IS MR. MUELLER
WHO WANTS HIS EVIDENCE AND
CONCLUSIONS TO BE CREDIBLE
WITH THE PUBLIC.
EVIDENCE IS BUILDING INSTEAD
THAT SOME OFFICIALS AT THE
AMERICAN PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTIONS.
CONGRESS NEEDS TO INSIST
THAT ITS RIGHTS AS A QUO
NOW, I'M NOT CALLING FOR
MUELLER TO BE FIRED.
IT'S TEMPTING BUT I'M NOT.
THIS INVESTIGATION.
AT LEAST PAUSE IT FOR A BIT.
I AGREE WITH WHAT ALAN
DERSHOWITZ SAID ON MY RADIO
SHOW THIS MORNING.
IN AND THOROUGHLY EXAMINE
THE INDIVIDUALS CONDUCTING
THIS PROBE AND FIRE ANYONE
INSIDE WHO EVEN A HINT OF AN
APPEARANCE OF A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST.
THAT'S ALL IT SHOULD TAKE.
THAT'S HOW HIGH THE STAKES
ARE OTHERWISE, THE PUBLIC
CONFIDENCE IN THE MUELLER
OPERATION WILL AND SHOULD
COLLAPSE UNDER ITS OWN